what's really essential that's the focus
of tonight's angle after almost two
months now of lockdown America is
finally reopening golf at NASCAR they
were on television this weekend and most
states are in the process of dismantling
their restrictions getting to the beated
for a lot of families is getting back to
normal which is great it's a sign of
hope it means that there's some light at
the end of the tunnel we're grateful
thankful appreciative that the judge
once again reinstated our First
Amendment right have a biblical command
to do it don't feel comfortable don't go
out but I'll say this I think it's great
to see things opening back up it's going
to be wonderful for the country hey
don't feel comfortable stay home that's
that's a lot of people are saying well
of course this is an exercise in basic
freedoms and it was met with a Pavlovian
response of outrage from the usual
lockdown lackeys there is still a great
deal of trepidation and uncertainty
about where all of this is headed that
we're in a very precarious situation
right now but experts warn that for some
states it's too much too soon
what I think you should take from it is
that we are in fact playing with fire
here fears of a second wave are
persistent and they are real of course
blue states such as Washington Michigan
California and Illinois are still slow
walking they're reopening but it's hard
to see when you really watch what's
happening around you it's hard to see it
lasting much longer while the virus took
a devastating toll on the country
hospitalizations coast-to-coast have
either declined or a leveling off that's
good news and also some promising
vaccine news also came out today from
Madonna and Wall Street reacted well
with the Dow jumping about four
percentage points more good news of
course we hope and pray the reopening
does go well but now that we've moved
past the immediate hospital crisis it's
time we think hard about what these
state leaders have done in the name of
safety now from the outset without the
involvement of state led
laterz governor's told us what was and
what was not essential
so only essential businesses could
remain open liquor stores pot
dispensaries abortion facilities pet and
garden stores essential churches gyms
schools basketball tennis courts
playgrounds not essential
so what criteria were used for many
people of faith communal service is
essential and arguably for them the most
essential thing in their lives and while
I'm really glad I could buy mountain
bags for my son's a few weeks ago why
are those shops open but outdoor
exercise classes not allowed so we see
this is all subjective it's all
subjective in the end and it's driven
usually by unaccountable technocrats but
it has profound consequences for our
lives only now we know just how screwed
up the Imperial College projections were
we talked about that I believe in early
April but now everybody understands it
no wonder the chief modeler Neil
Ferguson wouldn't share his computer
code with anyone that he used to derive
those projections now that we survey the
carnage human and economic we should
take stock of what really is essential
number one better experts it's time to
clear out the cobwebs why are people who
screwed up so badly in the past still in
their jobs in the private and public
sector they keep getting it wrong and
they keep staying in their jobs why
number two civil liberties obviously
essential freedom to petition the
government freedom to associate freedom
to worship freedom of speech freedom to
disagree with the prevailing winds
well these rights are inalienable they
can only be a bridge for a narrowly
tailored purpose not indefinitely I'm
here because you know we all deserve
freedom we've done everything we've been
asked to do enough is enough I think
need to realize their freedoms are being
taken away and if they don't stand up
for them right now there won't be any
freedom to stand up for these rights are
arguably more important during the
crisis that we're in right now than
during the good times I remember when
liberals used to believe this now the
American Civil Liberties Union well it
seems to only exist to defend illegal
immigrants and maybe abortion rights or
transgendered persons perhaps but these
things that we've been deprived of these
last two months don't hear from the ACLU
number three teaching the Constitution
is essential how many today really know
what it says what it means why it even
matters why does a declaration matter
well these documents ultimately protect
us from a government drunk on its own
power one that ends up subjugating its
own people for their own bottom line or
their own status or their own good
number for a prosperous economy is
essential that means not just for the
elites at the top but for the middle
class and entry-level workers as well we
all be important we're not getting paid
everything now is to pay my bills my
wife is a small business owner as well
we actually having to close the doors
there so obviously that crippled us
Democrats answer is socialism that's
only gonna bring misery we've seen it
across the globe over the decades the
last century we've seen it a growing
economy means a healthier America across
the board number five ending social
media censorship is essential if
something or someone doesn't comport
with the WH o--'s guidelines ANCOVA 19
guess what if you put that in the video
you post that your point of view maybe
with even evidence it'll be pulled down
anything that would go against World
Health Organization recommendations
would be a violation of our policy and
so remove is another really important
part of our policy
unbelievable now in a moment you're
gonna hear from my next guest a victim
of such censorship a renowned
epidemiologist in biostatistician number
six science that isn't infected by money
or politics is essential from climate
change to covert 19 we've seen far too
many members of the permanent medical
establishment may be compromised or at
least the appearance of being
compromised by ties to Big Pharma or
maybe even their own political
proclivities that has to end that has to
end in order for more Americans to trust
new vaccines other treatments or even
just their point of view on issues and
number 7 you the American people you are
essential your voices your hard work
your devotion to family to your faith to
playing by the rules this is your
government they work for you
never let them forget that you've always
had more good sense than most of the
so-called experts out there who want to
order you around and enjoy it keep
punching back keep questioning don't be
afraid you have a president who wants
you to be healthy who wants you to be
prosperous but most of all who wants you
to be free because without freedom the
rest really doesn't matter all that much
and that's the angle